hello and welcome everybody it's really
good to have you here with us today i'm
kim goff cruz i am the secretary and
vice president for university life here
at yale and i'm the university officer
who leads belonging at yale which is the
university's activities it's actual
initiative which is designed to enhance
diversity support equity and also
promote a sense of well-being a sense of
inclusion and belonging and welcome for
all of our community members
now today's conversation is one of a
series of occasional conversations that
we have uh sponsored by belonging at
yale
some of you know i know have been with
us on in our conversations with dolly
chug or with ibrahim kindy others of you
might have joined um
the first my story event that we had a
couple of weeks ago where we feature
students faculty staff and alumni to
talk about their sense of belonging on
campus a really really interesting event
so whether you've been with me before on
some of these other events or this is
your first time a hearty welcome to you
today
i do want to point out that the
belonging at yale website features a lot
of a calendar which has a lot of these
events and some of the taping of some of
the events so i ask you to check that
out regularly as well
but today our conversation is going to
be really interesting and very very much
very timely and on point
respecting all connecticut families the
legal parent-child relationship for
unmarried same-sex and non-biological
parents
this is a topic that's actually
interesting for everybody but i'm
particularly glad to host this event
this month in april when we celebrate
lgbtq pride
in conversation today are two of our
yale community members a faculty and
staff member
douglas lee james who teaches at the
yale law school is with us he is the
anne nyrowski professor of law and he
has a secondary appointment by the way
at the yale child study center
doug teaches courses on professional
responsibility family law the
constitutional family and also law and
sexuality
but he is for today's purposes the
principal drafter of the connecticut
parentage act
that act for those of you don't know
passed with near unanimous support which
is kind of hard to do nowadays so really
well done doug
near unanswered support from connecticut
legislators and was signed into law by
the governor in 2021
he is going to be in conversation with
deb stanley mccauley who is the
associate vice president for employee
engagement and workplace culture many of
us know that deb oversees the office of
diversity and inclusion work life and
child care programs and is also the key
person responsible for new haven hiring
initiative and she is also the chief
liaison for all of our affinity groups
so with that i know i'm looking forward
to this conversation as many of you are
and i'm going to turn it over to debbie
and doug
welcome everyone
in a particular welcome to you doug
thanks for
agreeing to be in conversation with me
thank you
uh i also understand that you've agreed
to be in conversation with all of our
participants so i want to remind all of
our participants that there's an
opportunity for them to contribute
questions during this presentation and
discussion using the question and answer
function at the bottom of the screen
so doug during our time together i've
got
questions a host of questions that are
going to fall into five different
categories the first is going to be a
broad set of questions that ground us in
this discussion
the second is i'm hoping to to delve
into the connecticut parentage act
and then i thought we'd move over to
maybe
understanding how you were able to get
the law passed
and then specifically about law and your
scholarship and then finally i'd love to
close us out with some guidance and some
advice that you might have
that we can implement long after today's
discussion so i hope that's the journey
that you're on it's the one that i'm
hoping we're going to go on together
great
so let me start thank you let me start
um with really a broad question
before we get into the connecticut
parentage act
can you just tell us what parentage is
it's not a term that most of us use uh
with any degree of regularity yeah so
it's in some ways a term of art but
parentage simply refers to the legal
parent-child relationship
um and so
our laws
have up until this point generally use
the term paternity and maternity
but the gender-neutral term parentage is
what our law is going to use now simply
to describe the status of being a legal
parent or a child of a legal parent okay
fantastic
and why is this important
yeah so
a lot
comes from having a legal parent-child
relationship so
um there's a host of parental rights but
also responsibilities that come with
parentage um so if you are a legal
parent you have
uh decision-making authority to make
decisions about where your child goes to
school and what kind of healthcare your
child gets and
you also if you and the
other person who might be the parent
aren't living together you have the
ability to seek custody or visitation
with your child
you also have an obligation to
financially support your child at least
until they're 18. so
it's not just rights it's important
responsibilities
and then a lot of other benefits turn on
having a legal parent-child relationship
federal and state benefits um social
security survivor benefits
access to things like health insurance
for a child and so having that legal
status is really important to families
thank you
and i imagine that there are many of our
participants that are probably taking
their own notes because as you and i
engage in conversation not only will i
walk away with with new knowledge i'm
hoping they will as well
so doug if we want to turn our attention
specifically to the connecticut
parentage act
can you give us a brief summary of what
it actually is
yeah so i guess um let me take off from
what we were just talking about which is
for most people they don't have to think
twice about the fact that they're a
legal parent of their child and for
those folks this law doesn't really
change much um but there are a lot of
people in connecticut and elsewhere
who
are raising their child and
yet the law might not treat them as a
legal parent
and some people
are aware of this and they try and do
things to
get around it other people might never
know that they actually aren't legally
recognized because everyone else is
treating them like a parent so what the
connecticut parentage act tries to do is
ensure that all children in connecticut
have equal access to the security of
that legal parent-child relationship by
having a more comprehensive and
inclusive parentage framework in our law
so that
people who otherwise might be treated as
legal strangers to their children will
now be treated as
legal parents to their children um so i
can walk through a few of the ways in
which that happens
very helpful thank you so for same-sex
couples um
ordinarily you will have one of the
parents not have a genetic connection to
the child and so if we have a legal
framework that is designed around
biology which most legal frameworks
around parent-child relationships are
that means for lgbtq parents half of
them
are going to not be treated as parents
and so we had cases in connecticut where
you had a same-sex couple who had a
child together through donor
insemination so they use donor sperm
and raise the kid together
and then they break up let's say the
kids six or eight or ten the
non-biological mother had no ability to
even get into court and say that she was
a parent of the child and seek custody
and so the law now changes that and so
now it says
um yes biology is still a basis on which
to establish parentage but there's other
bases as well and i tend to talk about
these as
intent and function so intent is
take that same-sex couple
they are having a child together with
donor sperm they both intend to be
parents of the child we should treat
them both as parents of the child if a
heterosexual married couple had a child
that way our law was treating them both
as parents we should do the same thing
for same-sex couples and we should do
the same thing for unmarried couples
the other dimension is is what i call
function and that's recognizing someone
as a parent because they're actually
parenting a child they've developed a
parent-child relationship so we had a
wonderful family who testified in
support of the act and they were a
married same-sex couple
and they had a child together with donor
sperm but one of the women also had a
child from a previous different sex
relationship
and that child was three when
uh the mom got together with her partner
and the child was now 14 when the bill
was up and he testified in support of
the bill and he had been being raised by
these two moms and he called them both
mom and his father wasn't really in the
picture and under our existing law there
was no way for him to
get the security of a legal parent-child
relationship with his non-biological
mother and intent wouldn't do him any
good because she wasn't there when he
was conceived
and so
we have now in the law something called
de facto parentage which will take
effect july 1 and that's essentially
treating people as parents because
they've developed a parent-child
relationship and are actually uh
parenting the child so overall the act
now provides routes to people for people
to be treated as parents based on
non-biological factors like intent and
function or marriage to the birth parent
in a gender-neutral way
thank you doug
so doug clearly um i'm a bit biased and
and believe that this was important but
overall why was it important to have
this act passed yeah so i mean as i was
saying a lot of people didn't have a
legal relationship but a lot of people
were actually um
remedying that by adopting their own
children
so um
it was really powerful when the chief
probate judge testified in support of
the bill because the probate court in
connecticut has jurisdiction over
adoptions
and she came in and said
i apologize to these families when they
come in to adopt their own kids they
shouldn't have to do this
um and
same-sex couples if
if they're being advised are told you
know do the adoption
there's still unfortunately are going to
be reasons to think about adoption as an
option given hostility in other states
but i think we now have the tools in
connecticut to give people the security
of parentage
without having to go through the
adoption process
and it's important because it also means
that kids will have the security of
having
a legal parent-child relationship so
that they have the right to maintain
relationships with their parents and if
one parent dies
they aren't then taken into state
custody or given to a family member
they're able to stay with their parent
there's just been too many sort of
heart-wrenching cases in which
children's relationships with the people
who are paring to parenting them are not
respected by our law and and it's
important that our law actually respect
families as they exist in our state
doug you you briefly mentioned other
states
so i'm wondering if you could talk with
us about
the process prior to
getting this act passed um
in connecticut were we leading or
lagging yeah um
so the act is modeled on a uniform act
the uniform parentage act of 2017 which
i was involved with that is
put out by the uniform law commission
which is a non-partisan group of law
professors state lawmakers state court
judges and lawyers and so that was
representing sort of the new best
practices model
and um
washington state adopted a version of it
uh maine california rhode island and
vermont all adopted versions of it
before we did
but not so bad to be you know in the
really in the forefront of that um and
our mission has been to especially try
to make new england a real zone of
equality here and so a version of the
bill is pending in massachusetts right
now um and
it's being fiercely debated and we are
hopeful that the massachusetts
legislature will pass it
but what's especially important about
connecticut is that when you look at a
state like california california already
had really good law so it didn't take
them much to get up to speed with this
connecticut's laws had not been updated
in decades
and so our laws still said husband and
wife even once we allowed same-sex
couples to marry we didn't change our
parentage laws
our laws still talked about children
quote born out of wedlock i mean terms
that are that we don't use anymore um
and so there were various ways in which
our laws just hadn't kept up we talked
about artificial insemination when
assisted reproduction involves a lot of
different procedures now and so
connecticut badly needed this and the
most important thing was that
connecticut was the only state in new
england that didn't have a path to
parentage for
a non-biological parent in an unmarried
couple
and so that's a you know
people shouldn't have to get married in
order for their parent-child
relationships to be recognized and that
was a really important advance in our
law given how far we had lagged behind
yeah thank you
so we sort of started with the
end i'd like to kind of go back and have
you talk with us about the journey can
you talk with us about um the process of
getting the law passed
what was the process what was your role
what role do others play
yeah so um i guess i'll just i'll start
by saying uh i had recently moved to
yale um and it was actually really kind
of amazing to me the ways in which
um
coming from the university allowed me to
speak to a lot of folks who
are decision makers in the state and
talk to them about this issue and i
don't know coming from california that i
had any similar opportunities
there
so it was nice to be able to do that so
i was teaching a course called the
constitution of the family in the law
school and
started inviting i invited the the new
chair from the judiciary committee to
come speak to the class
um
invited the head of the family law
section of the bar
and then eventually we had
the person that ended up being our chief
legislative sponsor representative jeff
curry who um carries a lot of the lgbtq
legislation in the
state house
and
you know the students were able to be a
part of this from the get-go which was
really nice we partnered with glaad
which is a lgbtq public interest firm
that handles new england and so they
were our main
partner and we created a coalition the
connecticut parentage act
we called it the we care coalition and
it included
it included a range of organizations and
stakeholders in the state
lgbt organizations children's rights
organizations um
healthcare providers
assisted reproduction groups in
fertility access advocacy organizations
um planned parenthood the aclu
and really wanted to make sure that we
were building this from the ground up
and
working with stakeholders to make sure
we were able to show lawmakers in the
state
why this was really important and also
working with state actors to make sure
we were getting buy-in and working with
them so
we worked very closely with the probate
court and the judicial branch
as well as with the
state agencies who are deal with these
matters like the department of social
services and the department of children
and families
and we were derailed by the pandemic in
the 2020 session but we came back in
2021 and
were able to pass it so the nicest thing
was that the some of the students who
had started working on it in their first
year of law school were able to see it
passed in their third year of law school
right before they graduated and that's a
an amazing accomplishment all around it
was interesting to hear you sort of
itemize the the different communities
that came together but it's really an
ecosystem so i'm wondering um have you
had other experiences prior to this
trying to have a law change or to change
laws
yeah so i've been very focused on
parentage um so i have been involved
with some of the other efforts in other
states um connecticut was
kind of refreshing and that it was a bit
more substantive than some of the
experiences we've had in other
jurisdictions
people
we're happy to get into the weeds
um and
and we included people early on i'm
involved in
in some uh legislative work that's
happening right now in colorado
and
um it's a scramble because
all the stakeholders weren't there at
the get-go
and so
i found in connecticut we were able to
get everyone to the table early on and
really
um
be able to be thoughtful about how we
were going to do this and make sure that
there weren't folks coming out of the
woodwork at the last minute saying well
what about me or i haven't been
consulted we really were exhausted and
the
legislators here i think really
appreciated that
okay fantastic um as you were talking uh
you know
you're really referencing culture change
in addition to behavior change and
mindset change um we live in polarized
times
changing laws on parents and children
might seem like a culture war issue
i'm wondering if you could talk with us
about
how you actually managed to get large
communities large populations to come on
board to support this particular law um
and at the same time because i heard you
you know you did made a nice comparison
to another example of where people
weren't early adopters so could you talk
a little bit more about that process and
um roles that you had taken on but also
i imagine you know if this is a
community building activity what other
activities occurred yeah so um
so it was really fascinating i think for
me but also for my students who at the
law school we tend to be too focused on
federal systems
we teach federal law primarily and focus
on the supreme court and congress and
the executive branch
and this was about the state and it was
focused on getting state lawmakers um
in a you know heavily democratic state
but still one with a significant
republican population in the legislature
to see this is an important issue and i
think we were all really heartened to
see that people were not just dug into
their positions people were willing to
listen and be educated
and many of the lawmakers had not
thought about this issue didn't know was
a problem but they were willing to
listen and be moved and
one example just sticks out in my mind
in our first hearing in the 2020 session
the ranking republican member on the
senate side of the judiciary committee
was there we had not
um we had had a meeting with him in
which he told that we told him what the
bill was but we otherwise hadn't had any
other conversations with him
but
one of the families testified and um
and they were in tears and he was in
tears
and he came over to us after the hearing
and said i signed on as a co-sponsor
during that testimony and so nothing's
more powerful i think than hearing from
families but you have to be willing to
listen and
the legislators were willing to listen
and then the 2021 session there was a
new house side ranking member on the
judiciary committee and he had founded
the conservative caucus in the
legislature and we were genuinely
concerned that it might be a
obstacle for us we had meetings with him
he was a lawyer
um he understood the issues and at the
end even if he wasn't um necessarily for
a lot of people the importance of the
lgbt equality dimensions of this was
huge he cared a lot about making sure
that children's lives were
respected and that we were protecting
their relationships and he became a
co-sponsor
and when the governor signed the bill on
pride day
in june of 2021 he was there
to witness that and so
i mean i it's naive of me to think that
this has application in a lot of other
settings but it was nice to see that in
our state people are still willing to
listen to each other and we had
republican support from the get-go
in both sessions um
and that was actually really important
for us to be able to move the bill
forward and to have people understand
the importance of something like this
yeah and i i really value storytelling
uh kim and her introductory remarks
talked about the last belonging
initiative which really focused on
telling your story so thank you for
sharing that i'm i'm wondering if
there's another side to this equation
and that's the lens of um
um either resistance or opposition did
you experience any and if so how do you
work either around it or through it or
conquer it
yeah so the depressing thing to me was
that the most resistance were from
lawyers
um
who don't like change
and
who don't so the the community of
lawyers who practice in these
cutting-edge areas of assisted
reproduction and lgbt family formation
in the state it's a very small group and
they were wonderful and helpful and
supportive but the the general
population of family lawyers took it
took more time to get them to a place
where they were comfortable with this um
and
i think for folks who are the ones that
are
you know doing cases and
having to the bill is 177 pages long so
people
quite reasonably don't like to have to
get upset but it was important and even
the courts were saying you know we have
to do new forms and the department of
public health
we have to do new kinds of forms here
and birth certificates and um we have
this very important what i take to be
maybe the most important part of the
bill and that is um we changed what were
previously under our law called
acknowledgments of paternity to
acknowledgments of parentage so under
federal law
every state is required to have what
they call a hospital-based system of
paternity registration
and so that's the most common way that
paternity is established for non-marital
children in the u.s
and so if you go to yale new haven you
know i think something like
um 40 to 50 percent of the births there
to unmarried women and something like 70
of the
um
of those cases are being
um
uh paternity's being established through
signing the acknowledgement of
fraternity the birth parent and the man
who says he's the biological father sign
it together
it has the force of a judgment and so
it establishes paternity and has legal
effect
and what we did was change it to an
acknowledgement of parentage and
keep the same folks consign it but also
open it to same-sex couples and others
using assisted reproduction that they
could sign it to say they're an intended
parent
and we're now the 10th state to do that
and
the department of public health wasn't
thrilled about this because they have
forms and computer systems and so so
really you know it took
getting people to see we're going to do
this and so come along with us so that
we can make it as painless as possible
um
but it's going to happen and it's
important that it happens and
and
concerns about changing forms or
learning new law are not sufficient
reasons to not do this so that was where
we had to deal with the most resistance
yeah so so let me move from resistance
to the word fear were there any
conversations that you were part of or
learned about where part of the
resistance may have been someone's
personal fear or
in other cases maybe lack of knowledge
about this particular community and the
the goals of this project
yeah so what's what was interesting in
connect so i think in other states
the fact that it protects lgbtq families
would be a problem
and um there might be reasons not to
promote parentage reform in that way
in connecticut
our legislators and and lots of people
in the state were actually eager they
got it when we talked about those
families yeah my friend or my neighbor
you know
had to do that and they shouldn't have
to do that um
but once you start digging into it so
for instance we have a provision in
there that allows a court to
recognize more than two parents for a
child
and that made some people uneasy and i
think it is fear and people started to
say well what if you know a
a heterosexual identified man says what
if my wife divorces me and gets married
to another man and he says he's a parent
and you have to sort of
educate folks on who these families are
in my own research i study some
multi-parent families and
courts actually
are only doing this when the person
really is the parent of the child
um and it's not being used by
step parents to assert parentage and so
i think people get worried
when they think that things are changing
but what they sometimes fail to see is
things have already changed we just
haven't really caught up to it and so
these families all exist
people might not think of them and
sometimes they're the most vulnerable
families the reason there's a third
parent is often that the biological
parents were facing
challenges that made it difficult to
parent and so
it's about protecting the children in
these families and i think
having people come back to that and see
that these families exist that's why the
family stories are so important um helps
deal with some of the fear which is just
fear of of the unknown and fear of
unintended consequences yeah thank you
thank you i love the power of the
storytelling um
you
talked about different partners i'm
wondering if we could focus a little bit
of on your law students yep um you had
partners in this work uh you led a
clinic you referenced your law students
could you uh share with me and us what
the role of the clinic was and
specifically the role that your law
students uh played yeah so um so i
should start by saying i'm not a
clinician um but dean gherkin sort of
set an example at the law school of
those of us on the doctrinal side being
able to do clinics when it intersects
with work we're doing and i you know i'm
a pr uh
was a practicing lawyer before becoming
an academic and got licensed in
connecticut to make sure i could do this
work um and so i started a legislative
advocacy clinic on this
and had students
working on it across the three years we
were doing it including the two sessions
in which it was introduced some of those
students carried over so we had
institutional memory and they were able
to lead teams in the last year
the really wonderful thing is that at
the law school you know i had students
who before coming to law school their
job was in public interest marketing and
consulting or communications and so
we were able to really
um have students with skill sets
you know i don't i'm not on social media
at all so students who could run the
social media accounts students who could
figure out how to do
um
uh certain kinds of communication
strategies and press releases and get
op-eds placed and so that was wonderful
and then we had students doing more
traditional legal work
we needed to research things we need to
go through the connecticut statutes and
amend all of the statutes that are
affected because there's a bunch of
statutes that use terms like paternity
and limit so think of probate statutes
we want to make sure that when if
someone dies
that all of the children we're having
recognized are going to be treated as
legitimate children of the deceita and
so we had to really do all of that and
students were tremendously helpful and
they also did a lot of legislative
advocacy so they um
they helped with testimony they met with
constituents and and
really drove letter writing
and so they were able to see every
dimension of it and you know able i hope
really be able to do the work that they
were most passionate about
and get an experience that they
otherwise weren't going to get since
most of the other work they were exposed
to was really litigation type work and
this was something something different
but they were
wonderful and
and it was made it so meaningful to be
able to get across the finish line with
them and it sounds like an amazing
learning experience that you don't often
get a chance to replicate from year to
year yes it sounds very exciting so doug
i started by saying i've got sort of
five categories of questions i'm gonna
switch us to my fourth category which is
about the law
and your scholarship
um you don't need to be a lawyer to know
that there's been a lot of change in in
the law
especially in the last 10 years
with regard to protections for a lesbian
gay bisexual transgender queer community
there seems to be more and more
protections but i know in florida which
i recently visited this year
in elsewhere there's current attention
to lgbtq issues specifically in schools
and in classrooms
can you say a bit about the lgbtq
community and the the law and its impact
and some of the decisions that some of
our politicians are making i'd love to
hear your perspective on that
yeah so unfortunately i mean as you
probably would guess
um parentage law in florida is also
really
dreadful for lgbtq people um and
parentage law in texas is not good for
lgbtq people so there are
zones like new england where
you know there's really
equality across multiple domains
employment parent-child relationships
schools
and then you get to other very popular
states like florida and texas in which
um right now in florida or texas if an
unmarried
lesbian couple has a child together and
breaks up
uh only the biological mother is a legal
parent um and
in texas the courts were even
saying
until recently that a married lesbian
couple who had a child together couldn't
both be parents of that child even
though we don't require that men married
to women be a biological father
um so so these are states where i think
lgbtq people and their families are
already feeling
um stigmatized and facing discrimination
the school's bills in
like in florida for instance
um are bad for children and bad for
parents
um
there are whether the law recognizes
them or not there are families
that include lgbtq parents in florida
and their kids are in school and we have
the luxury in connecticut of
being able to talk to our schools about
making sure that their curriculum is
inclusive and reflects the lives of the
children in the classroom and now in
florida people don't have that luxury
and those children are going to get
messages that their families don't
measure up and that's what we've been
fighting against for so long i mean in
texas it's even more horrifying given
the child protective services order that
um parents who are allowing their
children to have gender
affirming care
are essentially deemed to be committing
child abuse or neglect and
i mean these in some ways it's it goes
so
so much against
um conservative ideas about parental
rights and parental autonomy it's
parental rights and autonomy for some
people and not for others um and
it's obviously not good for children
to be in situations where not only is
their
emergent identity being stigmatized but
their parents are being told they can't
the thing i said is so important to
parentage making decisions for your
child about health care they can't make
those decisions and protect their
children so um i mean i'm sort of in
despair about some of this stuff but i
also know we have people who are working
on it including folks at yale
and at the yale child study center who
are trying to get people to understand
the
stakes and see that this is bad for
families and bad for children yeah
doug you used the word luxury when you
were responding to the last question
i have a note here where early on you
you referenced um making new england a
zone of equality um i'm a native of of
new haven which makes me a native of
connecticut and and still a resident and
i have to say you know listening to your
talk and and the outcome of
the collective effort
makes me proud to not just say i'm a
resident of new haven but but certainly
of connecticut
and so
you know i'm thinking about your work
through the lens of both scholarship but
also through legal lens and then also
you know the the sort of teaching and
exposure that you've created for your
students
so with can uh scholarship can sometimes
be highly theoretical
dealing with the ideas rather than the
practical matters
that might be different at a law school
maybe i guess
how do you see the relationship between
scholarship
uh in the changes in law is there one
and if so
what's what's your view
yeah
so um so some of my colleagues at the
law school would certainly say i'm not
sufficiently theoretical so i will just
start with that i care deeply about
having effects in the world um and
that's why i think the law school is
actually a really good setting for some
of the things that i was most interested
in um
i
i mean my research is motivated by my
commitments to certain values and
certain communities and so
um i found myself
um
really focusing on parent-child
relationships when i
understood the harms and so for me it's
not abstract or theoretical
and so i was interested in being able to
show people
how
the parentage framework works
to
marginalize some people and benefit
others
um i think one could have a fairly
simplistic view that just says well
non-biological parents you know because
biology is what mattered if you're not a
biological parent you're all treated the
same you have to adopt
but what i try to do in my work is
really dig down
into
the frameworks of each state because
this is a state by state question and
see that that's not really true if
you're a man married to a woman biology
isn't everything um and so it's some
people who are being
told they have to adopt their own
children and um
and also
biology has been deemed more essential
to
women to motherhood than to men or
fatherhood and so it carries forward
ideas we've had that it's sort of
women's natural destiny to be mothers
and
fathers can be
replaced by someone else and you see
that even in the way the law has
developed and so we were
it was much easier in some states to get
recognition for non-biological mothers
and same-sex couples because courts
essentially treated them like fathers
they satisfied paternity presumptions um
but
non-biological fathers in male same-sex
couples have had a much harder time and
actually their hard time has been like
the the experience of non-biological
mothers in different sex couples because
um our law has had a hard time saying
that a woman who doesn't give birth is a
parent
um and so
so i've been motivated by trying to get
people to see that the burdens of the
system don't fall evenly
the other thing is that this work it
sort of is a feedback loop for me so
doing this work
the place that we encountered the most
resistance was on what i call functional
parenthood
and that is someone's a parent because
they have formed a parent-child
relationship we have requirements they
have to reside with the child hold the
child out as their child
but they formed a parent-child
relationship they might have come into
the child's life when the child was one
they weren't there when the child was
born but this is the child's parent and
a lot of people resisted that because
they thought well then anyone's going to
be a parent and and and biological
parents are going to have to have their
rights infringed by these folks who are
really just mere helpers who are coming
in
um and
it just didn't reflect what i knew to be
the families who are affected by this
and so a colleague of mine courtney
joslin at uc davis who does this work as
well we decided to collect all of the
functional parent cases in the 29
jurisdictions that have these doctrines
and with a fabulous team of research
assistants at yale code them
and be able to see what what are the
cases and
and then now we're taking that research
so in massachusetts the big resistance
is to the functional parent provision
and um the advocates at glaad are
sending the art draft article and i'm in
meetings telling them so for instance in
83 of these 600 plus cases we have the
person who's saying they're a functional
parent is the child's primary caregiver
right it's like a lot of families facing
a lot of challenges in in 20 of the
cases
no parent no legal parent has been a
consistent presence in the child's life
so it's not what people envision it's
not the step parent who's saying you
know i want to be a parent too
um it's actually families you know you
get more of these cases in places like
kentucky and west virginia that um
sociologists are showing us in because
of the opioid epidemic a lot of children
are not residing with a
legal parent and so someone else is
parenting them and i i guess the bigger
push i mean the sense where i do get
more theoretical is i want people to see
that as parenting
like that is not just caregiving um the
parent parenting is a practice it's not
a status
and it's an investment as well yes yes
it's and it's hard work
yes
i have two children and i i agree with
that
doug so one might look at
this accomplishment and say you're all
done
i'm not sure you are so my next question
is really about
maybe it was about yesterday but i think
it's written as if we're looking at into
the future
um what's next
and more importantly what's next for you
what do you what else are you working on
yeah so um so i think i mean in some
ways
you know the most basic thing is getting
more states to treat people equally and
also getting other states to respect um
what we're doing in places like
connecticut
i just had a call yesterday with lawyers
who say you know i can get a connecticut
judgment and then i go to alabama and
the alabama department of vital records
says i don't have to treat this you know
or tennessee the case we were talking
about was tennessee i don't have to
treat this as a valid judgment i'm not
giving you a birth certificate um and so
we need to really focus on those
questions of
people being able to go across state
lines from
to hostile territory and be treated as
parents that's a big concern for people
it's why people still adopt even when
they live in friendly states um
even though the adoption decrees should
not be treated
differently than a judgment or any
anything else that has a court order
um so that's one thing
the things that follow
um
from passing parentage reform so for
instance there have been folks in
connecticut interested in
changing definitions of infertility so
that
same-sex couples and single women would
have access to
covered infertility treatment
and i think you'll see that continue to
take off
um
there's other so assisted reproduction
has become a big focus and so there's
also something we did in our law but
it's just a start is
how are we going to regulate that
industry and how are we going to provide
uh information to people who have donor
conceived
so making sure they get their medical
history that they have full information
so i think that's really a next frontier
and i think that's a tricky one because
i'm committed to things like people
should have access to
medical information and i'm also even
committed to things like
um
there should be
people should be counseled about the
importance of telling their children
that they were donor conceived about
thinking about whether they want a donor
who agrees to have their identity
released when the child is 18. um but i
also think some of those discussions
tend to
geneticize family relationships in ways
that are problematic for
my own work and lgbtq families
and so i think we need to be clear that
when we talk about relationships created
through donor gametes um
those are relationships that could have
different meanings but we shouldn't talk
about them as father biological fathers
parents you know i think it's important
and we shouldn't be thinking that
children are harmed by not having a
biological both biological parents
raising them and so for me i think an
important
and important next sort of bigger
project is just to get people to see
that
biology doesn't make parent-child
relationships and in our current world
of 23andme where we're really
fetishizing
ancestry and genetics
it's important to be able to get people
to appreciate um that that's not all
that family is yeah thank you so um for
our audience please feel free to type
questions in um i have just a couple
more questions so trying to bring us a
little bit uh closer to to closure um
this is sort of my fifth and final
category and i've i've sort of
titled it advice and guidance
um
kind of a two-part so
what should we all know
about parents and children in
connecticut first part
and then the second is what should we
tell our friends
so i'm i'm thinking specifically as you
started to describe that ecosystem
what role can i play
what role can other members that are
either going to watch this recorded
discussion or are with us today
um what actions can we take away from
today's discussion
yeah so i mean i think i hope people
appreciate
that what a lot of folks take for
granted other people spend a lot of time
and energy and money
um
uh making clear
um and so
um i know people still think
you know well if and and the one the one
legislator who voted against us he said
on the house floor well can't can't gay
people just adopt
and that was the remedy for him and i
will say in most like in european
countries increasingly that's they i
always say they talk about adoption as
the remedy and here we talk about it as
the harm because you shouldn't have to
i'm an adoptive parent
but i didn't have to adopt my own child
i adopted in the process in which
someone else is the parent at birth
but the folks that we're
helping here they're adopting their own
kids no one else is saying they're a
parent of that child and so
i think people need to experience and
appreciate that that
is not something parents should have to
go through um and so when we see that i
think it starts to get us to see that
you know our social understandings of
parenthood probably should match our
legal understandings um because if you
go to communities around our state
people are treating that non-biological
mother in the same-sex couple like a
parent the health care providers the
school the extended family the friends
the neighbors it's just the state that
hasn't been treating her that way and so
our laws should match in family law
especially i think it's important you
know we've talked about the difference
between sort of formal family law
regimes and functional family law
regimes and i'm on the functional side i
think our family law systems should
reflect the way people live their lives
rather than trying to channel people
into particular forms of family and
relationship by punishing people who
don't conform um and that's you know i i
think um
less conformity around family
arrangements is not a bad thing and we
should meet people where they are they
are where they are
thank you doug yeah thank you so doug i
have i can read one one of the i see one
question in the chat
um
and
it's personal so the person said this is
a personal question for doug
and the question reads how do you
organize your time
and keep energy for your scholarship and
life outside of work with this advocacy
any tips on how you do that well
i'm just exhausted all the time i think
um
so i have a three-year-old um so that
uh certainly takes a lot of time um i
mean i i fortunately have the luxury of
being at a law school where
at least my dean really
supported this work
and appreciated it and so if i was a
little less productive in
my scholarly writing
i didn't feel like i was
sort of shirking
but i will also say it was an intense
couple years
where as any time i had i was spending
on this legislation um and so
i fortunately was able to integrate it
into my teaching and so when i say i
taught a clinic i also got credit for
teaching a clinic and so there were two
semesters where that's what i that was
my course load teaching the clinic so it
really allowed me to focus on that work
the other thing is i think the synergy
between
the legislative advocacy and
my scholarship is helpful and so i
wasn't writing about things that i was
learning and
getting interested in and questions were
being framed by doing that legislative
work and so for me i was fortunate to
have and so now it spawned this sort of
series of projects um with my co-author
because we've gotten so invested in this
but yeah i was really happy when it
passed
um
both because it helped so many people in
the state but also because it meant i
could finally take the research leave
that i'd been delaying because i was
working on this all the time so it's not
easy
fantastic
i see another question has popped in
it says you mentioned one of the
testimonies from the legislative process
can you share some other stories
yes so um
meaning i assume meaning uh stories that
people told to lawmakers
that's my assumption yeah so i mean
actually we had um one of the most
amazing uh stories was from a yale law
school student who was in my clinic
and she
was born to she was born through one of
the first surgery arrangements in the
u.s involving a male same-sex couple
her fathers lived in california they
then moved to new mexico where she was
raised
and she's been involved with an advocacy
organization called collage which
represents children of lgbtq parents
and um she
both got collage on board to support our
bill and now i've been working with them
and they're involved in the
massachusetts effort as well but she
also testified
and um
[Music]
she testified about what it was like to
grow up because she's you know a law
student and so things have changed
dramatically and not have her
non-biological father be her legal
parent
um to have for a lot of her life the
woman who was the surrogate be her legal
mother on her birth certificate and to
also feel like people didn't
treat her family as
you know fully belonging um
and it i had a a republican legislator
on the committee call my cell phone
after that and said i don't know if you
saw this testimony but it was the most
amazing thing i've ever seen and i could
tell he said by
by her testimony that her fathers did an
incredible job raising her
and and then when we got to the senate
floor which was our last hurdle before
the governor's signature
our lead senate sponsor gave a speech in
which she um
talked about this student's testimony
and about her family and it was just um
it was
so great because so much of the law
school experience at yale is about
being analytical
and making arguments in law that
persuade decision makers
and she can do that but she also knew
how to make an argument
um
that was persuasive for emotional
reasons and for personal reasons and it
also she started crying during her
testimony and she talked to me
afterwards and said um i didn't expect
that you know i didn't think i was going
to be so moved but telling this group of
lawmakers about my experience was just
more moving than i imagined it to be um
and so it was things like that that
really um
i think that really stuck with me the
other thing i'll just say is there was
um testimony by someone from the family
law section of the connecticut bar in
the first session that we were in
and um
and what she
what she missed was that right before
her was this family i talked about with
the de facto mother who had been raising
the kid since he was three and now he
was 14. and that had everyone in tears
but this woman from the bar wasn't there
for that and so she just waltzed in when
they called her and gave this testimony
about how bad de facto parentage was
um because suddenly anyone was going to
be a parent you could have 100 parents
and these people aren't really parents
and the legislators just tore into her
and started saying like you mean to tell
me this and then finally the the
co-chair of judiciary the senate side
said
because she then kept saying she kept
saying step parents are going to be
parents and he said i'm a stepfather
and i'm the only father my children know
and you have to stop saying that all
step parents are not parents you know so
it really was just like one um know your
audience and see what comes before you
um but two like it just showed how
people's actual experiences can rebut
some of these arguments that are just
about assumptions
from people who don't really know what
people's family lives are like yeah
yeah and i love in that story um the the
change in role
which
uh the i perspective that you were
describing right
automatically it became personal yes i
do think when things become personal i
think that's when we can make even more
more progress yeah um so doug
i am trying to keep my eye on the q a
and uh we have another question there
was a comment where someone said thank
you so very much for today's talk so i
will extend that gratitude to you the
next question says
how uh how intersectional are issues
about parentage do you run into
questions of racism and other forms of
discrimination
yeah so um
it's a great question so certainly i
think um what people fail to realize is
that um
uh
if you look at family demographics
um
families marital families and
non-marital families look different
so we are in a world in the u.s of
marriage decline rates of marriage used
to be high their they've gotten lower
and lower rates of marriage used to be
similar across
racial and ethnic groups but they now
diverge significantly
so african americans and latinos are
less likely to be married than uh whites
and
asian americans
um it's also stratified by class
uh people with higher incomes and more
education are more likely to be married
and so for us
you know a big part of this was
protecting parents and children in
non-marital families and so i think that
does have race and class dimensions um
and
and i think so that was important to get
people to see that look you might think
that we're just sorting people based on
are you a biological parent are you a
marital parent but that actually has a
disparate impact
based on race and class
there's also intersections with
immigration and so we did one of the
sponsors one of the members of our
coalition was an immigration
organization because um i'm sure you
remember early on in our efforts the
trump administration was separating
children at the border
and
the federal government decided they were
going to use dna tests to determine
whether people were actually parents of
the child well to me that's not
determining whether someone's actually a
parent of the child and in fact they
weren't even asking whether the home
jurisdiction would treat them as a
parent it was just sort of we decided
this is what a parent-child relationship
is and surprise you know some of those
people were not genetic parents but they
were the primary caregivers of those
children and so um so people saw the
importance of more expansive
understandings of family relationships
in the immigration setting as well
doug the last comment that i see is just
that
it is another note of gratitude it says
thank you for this session i'm amazed at
what i didn't know and you have shed
some light around unanswered questions
that i had
and so um i'm going to take us to a
close
and
first i'm going to practice gratitude as
well and i want to say thank you my
thank yous are probably a little bit
different um mine is sort of a selfish
thinking because at the beginning you
said you moved to connecticut so let me
say very selfishly i'm so glad that you
live in connecticut and that we are
working towards creating
um a region um where there is equality
but when i start to think about the
state that i'm living in it's really
nice to know that we're making positive
movement towards you know creating a
world of inclusion so i'm selfishly
saying thank you and and
i hope you stay in connecticut for quite
some time
to transform um our state and us as
people
um you use the word we decide it and so
i'm gonna switch that to i decided um i
decided that i'm going to close out by
saying you rock
and thank you so much for all of your
time today but i think the thank you
also needs to be extended to the team of
individuals that you've constantly
itemized as you were answering questions
that are part of that village that is
helping to make change in connecticut
and also in in other states where change
is certainly necessary
i just want to close with one question
and mine is sort of around hopefulness
um as you think about the progress
that's been made within our state and
then you look outside of connecticut um
u.s and beyond
are you hopeful
that in maybe this lifetime your
lifetime or your
child's lifetime
that um we as a society will become much
more inclusive
uh and practice more equity
yeah um
i mean things are really depressing
right now
um and
i was just uh
i'm a
co-author on a case book on sexuality
and gender identity and the law and
we're doing a new addition and my
co-author was saying like if you went
back to
10 years ago
and actually the the author who started
the book in the um early 90s said
no idea that these issues i wrote about
then were going to be the main issues
now it was anti-anti-gay curriculum laws
you know
just so so that
leaves me with a lot of worry but i also
think that the
experience here has shown that people
who are willing to listen can be moved
and that
people care about
their neighbors and family members and
more and more people are going to be
living in family arrangements that don't
look like their parents family
arrangements and
i'm
an example of having parents who come
around to understanding the importance
of respecting people even if they don't
conform to what your life looked like um
and so i i do have some optimism around
that and you know that seeing the kids
in florida and texas push back also
gives me optimism yeah i agree um and
our advocates are becoming younger and
younger and younger which i think is
fantastic and using their voice not
finding it but using their voice so i'm
going to close out again by saying thank
you very much and to thank you to all of
the attendees for today's webinar
brief reminder that belonging at yale
website has a calendar of upcoming
events on topics that enhance diversity
support equity and promote
a welcoming environment and inclusive
environment here at yale
thank you doug for spending your
afternoon and almost a little bit of
your evening with us and everyone else
thank you so much and have a great
evening and a great weekend take care
thank you
you